and finally new rules someone has to
break it to America's travel vloggers
that the part of life where you're
retired and Joyride around the country
uh that's supposed to come after the
working for a living part not before
[Applause]
now in recent weeks the country has been
transfixed with the story of a young
woman murdered while traveling in a van
with her boyfriend and while too much
attention has already been paid this
case has taught me a few things first
that Nancy Grace is still alive
all right
and second how extensive is this
movement of young hipsters rejecting the
dreary working life of us normies to
instead explore the country in a van
which I found very odd this is what
retirees do they get an RV and visit our
nation's many historic outlet malls
it's what Clarence Thomas and His
hideous wife do for kicks you want to
emulate them what's next taking up
shooting birds on the ground like Dick
Cheney
but
but of course the whole point of Van
life is to film your travels and put
them on YouTube you're not a hobo you're
a content provider
let other people work stupid jobs like
nurse or teacher you figured out a way
to monetize [ __ ] off
yeah you and everybody else in your
generation according to the LA Times
content creators are the fastest growing
type of small business in the U.S by one
estimate over 50 million people
worldwide now consider themselves to be
online creators or influencers
when we used to ask kids what do you
want to be when you grow up they'd say
firefighter astronaut now most 60 year
olds would probably say I want to be
Instagram famous [ __ ]
[Applause]
and I guess why not the supposedly media
Savvy Millennials and gen's ears really
do buy stuff just because some ding dong
holds it up on Instagram
they laugh at Boomers buying crap on QVC
but you're doing the same thing
Grandma's buying Tupperware you're
selling mascara to each other
the only difference is she's suffering
from dementia what's your excuse
I mean I get why nobody wants the jobs
that Del taco is offering
that's exactly where Brian laundry
should be working
he was never destined to be insta-famous
he was destined to forget the fries in
my cheeseburger combo
I keep hearing that there are no good
jobs out there well there certainly are
many shitty jobs out there but there are
also millions of openings in
professional and business services
Education Health construction retail
manufacturing America right now has more
job openings than at any time in its
history and more than there are people
looking
a lot of the time there are no good jobs
out there just means I want to be Kim
Kardashian
it means I want my job to be I'm me and
people pay to watch that
what's the fallback career marijuana
tester
[Applause]
72 percent of gen Z's say they'd like to
be an online celebrity they don't even
want to achieve something that makes
them famous that would involve that
pesky step of developing some sort of
Talent OR skill no
getting followers that is the
achievement I'd say take a good long
look at yourself but plainly that's all
you do all day
we we spent decades dismantling the
patriarchal notion that women should
stay home and not work and then the
Kardashian phenomenon happened now it
seems like Millions want to
you know stay home and not work
this generation's financial plan is
hitting the jackpot getting paid to do
nothing is their highest goal so spoiled
by parents who told them all you have to
do is do you
that they think it's fascinating for us
to watch them order eggs at a diner
but how long can we go on selling each
other our life stories as the basis for
an economy it doesn't feel sustainable
you can't all be the Truman Joe
most of the time what these vloggers are
reporting on is in their travel is is
just themselves this just in we woke up
oh
it's hard to wrap my head around this
level of narcissism of so many people
trying to make a living by taking
pictures of themselves like that their
own paparazzi
everyone wants to know what went on in
that van between Brian and Gabby I want
to know why filming van life is
something anyone would find remotely
interesting to begin with
home movies I've never been interesting
that is as true in the YouTube era as it
was back when kids had to sit through
Uncle Morty's super rate footage of his
trip to Cypress Gardens
but at least he didn't ask us to hit the
like button and subscribe to it
I'm sorry but Brian laundry was not an
interesting person until he became a
person of interest
[Applause]
when I read about this couple riding
around for four months I thought how
lovely that would have been when I was
22. I don't remember having the freedom
to just drive around the country I had
to sell drugs
you did
I was starting a career
I had to pay for it nobody these days
seems to be up for enduring those early
shitty jobs and shitty Apartments we all
had as a matter of course on the way to
something better
one of the most popular games of the
pandemic was Nintendo's Animal Crossing
a game where you don't do anything there
are no bad guys you can't die you can't
win or lose you just kind of [ __ ] around
what a perfect game for this generation
but what I don't get about them is if
you think having a job is so terrible
how come you're always trying to get
people fired